IS FRESH OFF HER MEETING WITH
KANYE WEST.
SHE WILL GIVE US ALL OF THE
DETAILS LATER IN THIS MEETING.
HERE'S OUR OPENING MONOLOGUE.
APPEASEMENT NEVER WORKS.
TONIGHT, WE HAVE ANOTHER
REMINDER.
THE ISRAELI PRIME MINISTER
BENJAMIN NETANYAHU IS NOW
SOUNDING THE ALARM AND AS PER
USUAL, THE PRIME MINISTER HAS
PURE MORAL CLARITY.
I'VE BEEN SAYING THIS FOR YEARS.
NOW THE PRIME MINISTER IS
REVEALING ACCORDING TO THOUSANDS
OF PAGES OF OFFICIAL DOCUMENTS
OBTAINED BY INTELLIGENCE
SOURCES, IRAN'S NUCLEAR PROGRAM
AS ALIVE AND WELL.
THE IRANIANS CALL IT PROJECT A
MOD.
IT IS SECRET, ILLICIT, IT IS AN
ONGOING SCHEME TO CONTRACT ON MY
CONSTRUCT NUCLEAR WEAPONS
AMENDED MEANS TO DELIVER THAT BY
INCLUDING A VERY SPECIFIC PLAN
TO DEVELOP FIVE WARHEADS, EACH
CONTAINING A 10-KILOTON YIELD.
HERE IS WHAT THE PRIME MINISTER
OF NONTENURE SAID ABOUT THIS
PROGRAM AND INCREDIBLE PRESS
CONFERENCE, INCREDIBLE
INTELLIGENCE EARLIER TODAY.
>> THIS WAS IRAN'S CHANCE TO
FULLY COME CLEAN.
THEY COULD TELL THE TRUTH.
THEY COULD SAY, WE HAVE THIS
PROGRAM, THIS SECRET PROGRAM,
IT'S OVER, IT DOESN'T EXIST, WE
DESTROYED THEM.
HERE'S WHAT IRAN ACTUALLY TOLD
THEM.
IT SAID, IRAN DENIED THE
EXISTENCE OF A COORDINATE
PROGRAM AND THE DEVELOPMENT OF
THE NUCLEAR EXPLOSIVE DEVICE AND
SPECIFICALLY DENIED THE
EXISTENCE OF THE PLAN.
THE MATERIAL PROVES OTHERWISE,
THEY AUTHORIZED, INITIATED, AND
FUNDED PROJECT AMAD.
HERE'S ANOTHER DOCUMENT FROM THE
ARCHIVE.
A MASTER PLAN OF PROJECT AMAD.
>> Sean: I'M TOLD THE
PRIME MINISTER DID ALL THAT,
ENTIRE PRESENTATION, POWERPOINT,
WITHOUT ANY NOTES.
REMEMBER, THIS JUST COMES THREE
YEARS AFTER PRESIDENT OBAMA
SIGNED OFF ON WHAT IS THE WORST
TO DEAL IN THE HISTORY OF THE
UNITED STATES, FRANKLY, THE
WORLD.
THE MULTILATERAL AGREEMENT WHERE
THE UNITED STATES AGREED TO
UNLOCK $150 BILLION ARE FROZEN
IRANIAN ASSETS AND TO SEND
ANOTHER 1.7 BILLION AND CASH
INCLUDING AN INITIAL
$400 MILLION DOWN PAYMENT,
LITERALLY SHIPPED AND CARGO
PLANES AND CASH AND OTHER
CURRENCIES.
SUBCRITICAL SANCTIONS WERE
LIFTED AT THE TIME.
WHAT DID WE GET IN RETURN?
A PROMISE FROM RADICAL ISLAMIC
MULLAHS OF IRAN THAT THEY
TEMPORARILY HALT THEIR NUCLEAR
WEAPONS PROGRAM?
THE SAME MULLAHS THAT ACTIVELY
PLAN FOR THE DESTRUCTION OF
ISRAEL?
THE SAME MUSCLES THAT CHANT
"DEATH TO AMERICA, DEATH TO
ISRAEL," THAT FUND TERRORISM ALL
OVER THE WAR THAT ARE FIGHTING
PROXY WAR AFTER PROXY WAR IN
IRAQ AND SYRIA AND ELSEWHERE?
THE SAME MULLAHS ARE RESPONSIBLE
FOR KILLING U.S. SOLDIERS IN
IRAQ, HOLDING OTHER AMERICANS
HOSTAGE?
REMEMBER, OBAMA TOLD US, THIS
WAS GOOD FOR THE WORLD?
WE WARNED YOU.
THIS AGREEMENT WAS ALWAYS A
SHAM.
NO DIFFERENT THAN WHEN NEVILLE
CHAMBERLAIN DECLARED PEACE IN
HIS TIME AND SIGNED OFF ON A
DEAL TRYING TO APPEASE ADOLF
HITLER.
NO DIFFERENT THAN WHEN
BILL CLINTON APPEASED
KIM JONG UN'S FATHER, KIM JONG
IL, IN THE AGREEMENT CLINTON
PROMISED THIS WAS A GOOD DEAL
FOR THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
IT WILL HALT NORTH KOREA'S
NUCLEAR WEAPONS PROGRAM AND
AMBITION ONCE AND FOR ALL.
IN 2015, OBAMA WANTED YOU TO
BELIEVE ONCE AGAIN, IF ONLY WE
KISSED THE RINGS OF TEST BEDS
AND RADICALS AND DICTATORS,
SOMEHOW, THEY WILL BE NICE TO
US.
FAULTY, FIELD LOGIC.
APPEASEMENT NEVER WORKS.
PRESIDENT TRUMP NOW FACES A VERY
IMPORTANT DECISION, WHETHER OR
NOT TO HOLD IRAN ACCOUNTABLE AND
PULL THE U.S. OUT OF THIS DEEPLY
FLAWED AGREEMENT.
HERE IS HOW PRESIDENT TRUMP
REACTED TO THIS INCREDIBLE,
BREAKING DEVELOPMENT TODAY.
>> SEVEN YEARS, THAT DEAL WILL
HAVE EXPIRED AND IRAN IS FREE TO
GO AHEAD AND CREATE NUCLEAR
WEAPONS.
THAT'S NOT ACCEPTABLE.
SEVEN YEARS IS TOMORROW.
IT'S A HORRIBLE AGREEMENT FOR
THE UNITED STATES, INCLUDING THE
FACT, MR. PRESIDENT, THAT WE
GAVE IRAN
$150,000,000,000.1.8 BILLION IN
CASH.
NIGERIA WOULD LIKE SOME OF THAT.
1.8 BILLION IN CASH.
$150 BILLION.
YOU KNOW WHAT WE GOT?
WE GOT NOTHING.
THAT DOESN'T MEAN I WOULD NOT
NEGOTIATE A NEW IDEA.
WE'LL SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
BUT I THINK IF ANYTHING, WHAT IS
HAPPENING TODAY AND WHAT HAS
HAPPENED OVER THE LAST LITTLE
WHILE AND WHAT WE'VE LEARNED HAS
REALLY SHOWN THAT I'VE BEEN 100%
RIGHT.
>> Sean: THERE ARE MOMENTS IN
HISTORY YOU HAVE TO LEARN FROM
AND THE DEVASTATING FAILURES OF
APPEASEMENT, NEVILLE
CHAMBERLAIN, BILL CLINTON,
PRESIDENT OBAMA IN HIS WAY, IT
ALL HAS TAUGHT US, APPEASEMENT
NEVER WORKS.
PEACE THROUGH STRENGTH DOES WORK
PEACE THROUGH STRENGTH DOES WOR
WORK.
THIS BRINGS US TO OUR NEXT
TOPIC.
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S HISTORIC
DIPLOMATIC PROGRESS ON THE
KOREAN PENINSULA.
INSTEAD OF TRYING TO APPEASE
KIM JONG UN OR BRIBE HIM WITH
BOATLOADS OF CASH,
PRESIDENT TRUMP TOOK SOME VERY
TOUGH MEASURES.
IN THE EARLY MONTHS OF THE
ADMINISTRATION, REMEMBER THE
PRESIDENT AND GREENISH SANCTIONS
OF THE NORTH KOREAN REGIME.
HE SENT MULTIPLE CARRIER STRIKE
GROUPS ARE THE REASON.
HE SQUEEZED HER NORTH KOREA'S
MOST IMPORTANT STRATEGIC
PARTNER, CHINA, ALL THE WHILE
CALLING HIM DRUNK ON LITTLE
ROCKET MAN AND SAYING OUR BUTTON
WORKS.
THE MEDIA FREAKED OUT,
PROCLAIMED TRUMP WILL LEAD US TO
A NUCLEAR WAR.
THEY SAID THE SAME THING WHEN
REAGAN CALLED THE FORMER
SOVIET UNION ON THE EVIL EMPIRE.
WE KNEW BETTER ANOTHER
PRESIDENT'S STRATEGY HAS SEEN
SIGNIFICANT PROGRESS THAT IS
GREAT FOR THE WORLD.
FOR THE FIRST TIME EVER, THIS IS
HISTORIC THEM A LOOK AT THIS.
KIM JONG UN CROSSING INTO
SOUTH KOREA FOR THIS HISTORIC
THEM A POSITIVE MEETING WITH
SOUTH KOREAN PRESIDENT MOON.
A MEETING BETWEEN
PRESIDENT TRUMP, PRESIDENT MOON,
AND KIM JONG UN AS MOVING
FORWARD AS PLANNED.
NOT DONE YET.
CERTAINLY GOOD PROGRESS.
ALSO BREAKING TODAY, ACCORDING
TO THE SOUTH KOREAN SOURCES, THE
NORTH KOREAN DICTATOR IS WILLING
TO GIVE UP HIS NUCLEAR WEAPONS
PROGRAM COMPLETELY AS LONG AS
THE UNITED STATES AGREED TO
OFFICIALLY END OF THE KOREAN WAR
AND PROMISED NOT TO LAUNCH AN
ATTACK.
OVER THE WEEKEND DURING A RALLY
IN MICHIGAN, THE CROWD REACTED,
THIS IS WHEN THE PRESIDENT WAS
GOING TO BE AT THE WHITE HOUSE
CORRESPONDENTS DINNER, AND I
PROUDLY, 30 YEARS IN RADIO, 20
YEARS IN TB, HAVE NEVER BEEN TO
A SINGLE ONE.
I AM PROUD OF THAT.
THIS IS THE CROWD REACTED TO THE
DEVELOPMENTS ON THE KOREAN
PENINSULA.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> I REMEMBER, YOU KNOW, IT WAS
VERY ROUGH.
THREE, FOUR MONTHS AGO.
>> [CROWD CHANTING]
>> [LAUGHS]
>> THAT'S VERY NICE.
THANK YOU.
THAT'S VERY NICE.
NOBEL.
I JUST WANT TO GET THE JOB DONE.
>> Sean: I JUST WANT TO GET
THE JOB DONE.
EVERYONE ON THE FAKE NEWS MEDIA,
THEIR HEADS EXPLODED.
THE SOUTH KOREAN PRESIDENT
AGREES MOON IS NOW ECHOING
THESE CALLS FOR PRESIDENT TRUMP
TO IN FACT, YES, RECEIVE THE
NOBEL PEACE PRIZE.
LET'S HOPE WE CAN PULL THIS OFF.
THESE HISTORIC AND NOW FOR
RAPIDLY EVOLVING DEVELOPMENTS
FROM A KOREAN PENINSULA SHOULD
GIVE EVERYONE AROUND THE WORLD A
SENSE OF CAUTIOUS OPTIMISM AND
SOME ARE EVEN CALLING
PRESIDENT TRUMP A
TRANSFORMATIONAL PRESIDENT.
THREE WORDS: PEACE THROUGH
STRENGTH.
WE'LL BRING YOU MORE ON THIS
LATER IN THE SHOW BUT FIRST, THE
DEEP STATE IS CRUMBLING RIGHT
BEFORE OUR EYES.
NEARLY FIVE YEARS AGO, THE
NATIONAL INTELLIGENCE DIRECTOR
JAMES CLAPPER, REMEMBER, HE
BLATANTLY PERJURED HIMSELF IN
FRONT OF CONGRESS?
YOU MAY REMEMBER THIS MOMENT.
>> DOES THE NSA COLLECT ANY TYPE
OF DATA AT ALL ON MILLIONS OR
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF
AMERICANS?
>> NO, SIR.
>> IT DOES NOT?
>> NOT WITTINGLY.
THERE ARE CASES WHERE THEY COULD
INADVERTENTLY, PERHAPS COLLECT,
BUT NOT WITTINGLY.
>> Sean: OF COURSE, A SHORT
TIME LATER, WE LEARNED THE NSA
WAS COLLECTING DATA.
CLAPPER KNEW IT AND HE LIED.
HE WAS NEVER CHARGED LIKE
GENERAL FLYNN WITH LYING.
THIS CASE, PERJURY.
NOW CLAPPER HAS BEEN CAUGHT IN
YET ANOTHER BOLD FACE LIE.
ACCORDING TO A REPORT FROM THE
HOUSE AND TELL COMMITTEE DURING
A CLOSED-DOOR HEARING,
CLAPPER FLATLY DENIED EVER
DISCUSSING THAT PHONY CLINTON
BOUGHT AND PAID FOR STEEL
RUSSIAN DOSSIER WITH A MEMBER OF
THE MEDIA.
HE ALSO REPEATED THIS CLAIM IN
MARCH DURING AN INTERVIEW WITH
DON LEMON AT CNN.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> I DO NOT HAVE ANY CONTACT
WITH MEDIA UNTIL AFTER I LEFT
THE GOVERNMENT ON THE 20TH OF
JANUARY.
SO I DON'T QUITE UNDERSTAND WHAT
I READ THAT SOMEHOW I LEAKED
ABOUT THE DOSSIER.
>> YOU DIDN'T LIKE ANYTHING
ABOUT THE DOSSIER TO ANYBODY?
>> NO.
I MEAN, I TALKED ABOUT IT AFTER
I LEFT THE GOVERNMENT.
BUT NOT DURING THAT PERIOD AND
CERTAINLY NOT BETWEEN THE SIXTH
OF JANUARY AND THE TENTH WHEN
THE PRESIDENT-ELECT HIMSELF
TALKED ABOUT IT.
>> Sean: AN INCREDIBLE
DEVELOPMENT.
THE INTEL COMMITTEE'S REPORT
FOUND THAT CLAPPER "ADMITTED TO
THE HOUSE PERMANENT SELECT
COMMITTEE ON INTELLIGENCE AND
PRIVATE TESTIMONY THAT HE
BRIEFED CNN'S JAKE TAPPER IN
EARLY JANUARY 2017."
THIS WAS SHORTLY BEFORE TRUMP'S
INAUGURATION.
TAPPER ALONG WITH TWO OTHER
JOURNALISTS, SO-CALLED
JOURNALIST FROM CNN, PUBLISHED A
REPORT DETAILING HOW TRUMP WAS
BRIEFED ABOUT THE STEELE
DOSSIER.
A SHORT TIME LATER,
JAMES CLAPPER, OH, HE'S HIRED BY
FAKE NEWS CNN AS AN ANALYST.
YOU CONNECT THE DOTS.
PRESIDENT TRUMP REACTED ON
TWITTER, WRITING...
NOW IF CLAPPER DOES NOT FACE
LEGAL JEOPARDY OVER THIS BLATANT
PERJURY TO CONGRESS, IT WILL BE
YET ONE MORE EXAMPLE OF WHAT I
SAY IS OUR TWO TIERED SYSTEM OF
JUSTICE.
HE'LL GO WITH THE
HILLARY CLINTON SYSTEM OF
JUSTICE.
LET'S TURN TO THE MAINSTREAM
MEDIA.
IF YOU THOUGHT THEY COULDN'T GET
ANY MORE ANTI-TRUMP OR DOWNRIGHT
VULGAR, THINK AGAIN.
THEY OUTED THEMSELVES OVER THE
WEEKEND.
THE WHITE HOUSE CORRESPONDENTS
ASSOCIATION HELD THEIR ANNUAL
DINNER.
I AM SO PROUD I HAVE NEVER BEEN,
WHERE THEY TAKE SOME TIME TO
HONOR THE MEDIA, PAT THEMSELVES
ON THE BACK, JUST LIKE THEIR
HOLLYWOOD BUDDIES, FOR THEIR
COURAGEOUS WORK OF ECHOING EACH
OTHER.
PRESIDENT TRUMP, WHO DID NOT
ATTEND, PREVIEWED THE DINNER AT
HIS RALLY IN MICHIGAN.
HE DECIDED TO STAY WITH THE
PEOPLE, JUST LIKE HE DID LAST
YEAR.
GOOD CHOICE.
>> BY THE WAY, BY THE WAY, BY
THE WAY, IS THIS BETTER THAN
THAT PHONY WASHINGTON
WHITE HOUSE CORRESPONDENTS
DINNER?
IS THIS MORE FUN?
I COULD BE UP THERE TONIGHT
SMILING LIKE I LOVE WHEN THEY
ARE HITTING YOU COME I SHOT
AFTER SHOT, THESE PEOPLE, THEY
HATE YOUR GUTS, SHOT.
AND YOU KNOW, YOU GOT TO SMILE.
AND IF YOU DON'T SMILE, THEY
WILL SAY, HE WAS TERRIBLE, HE
COULDN'T TAKE A HIT, AND IF YOU
DO SMILE, THEY WILL SAY, WHAT
DID HE SMILE ABOUT?
THERE IS NO WINNING.
>> Sean: PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
DESCRIPTION, ALL TOO ACCURATE.
THIS YEAR'S SHOW FEATURED SUCH
SO-CALLED COMEDIAN, FORMER DAILY
SHOW CONTRIBUTOR, NEVER HEARD OF
HER BEFORE, MICHELLE WOLF,
DELIVERING A PERFORMANCE THAT IS
SO VILE, ONE-SIDED,
CRINGEWORTHY, YOU MIGHT WANT TO
COVER YOUR EARS OF IO KIDS IN
THE LIVING ROOM.
>> MIKE PENCE IS ALSO VERY
ANTICHOICE.
HE THINKS ABORTION IS MURDER.
WHICH, FIRST OF ALL, DON'T KNOCK
IT TILL YOU TRY IT.
AND WHEN YOU DO TRY IT, REALLY
KNOCK IT.
YOU KNOW IT, YOU GOT TO GET THAT
BABY OUT OF THERE.
YOU GUYS GOTTA STOP PUTTING
KELLYANNE ON YOUR SHOW.
ALL SHE DOES IS LIE.
IF YOU DON'T GIVE HER A
PLATFORM, SHE HAS NOWHERE TO
LIE.
IT'S LIKE THAT OLD SAYING, IF A
TREE FALLS IN THE WOODS, HOW DO
WE GET KELLYANNE UNDER THAT
TREE?
I'M NOT SUGGESTING SHE GETS
HURT, JUST STUCK.
IVANKA CLAIMS        CLEANS UP N
IVANKA CLAIMS        CLEANS UP C
IVANKA CLAIMS        CLEANS UP .
SHE'S THE DIAPER GENIE OF THE
ADMINISTRATION.
ON THE OUTSIDE SHE LOOKS SWEET
BUT ON THE INSIDE, IT'S STILL
[BLEEP].
>> Sean: NOT EVEN FUNNY.
IF YOU THINK THAT'S BAD, SHE
SAVED HER WORST REMARKS FOR
SARAH SANDERS, WHO WAS SITTING
JUST FEET AWAY.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> AND OF COURSE, WE HAVE SARAH
HUCKABEE SANDERS, WE ARE GRACED
WITH SARAH'S PRESENCE TONIGHT.
I HAVE TO SAY, I AM A LITTLE
STARSTRUCK.
I LOVE YOU AS AUNT LYDIA AND
"THE HANDMAID'S TALE."
I ACTUALLY REALLY LIKE SARAH.
I THINK SHE'S VERY RESOURCEFUL.
LIKE, SHE BURNS FACTS AND THEN
SHE USES THE ASH TO CREATE A
PERFECT SMOKY EYE.
LIKE, MAYBE SHE'S BORN WITH IT.
MAYBE ITS ALLIES.
AND I'VE NEVER REALLY SURE WHAT
TO CALL SARAH HUCKABEE SANDERS.
YOU KNOW?
IS THAT SARAH SANDERS, IS IT
SARAH HUCKABEE SANDERS, IS IT
BECAUSE IN HUCKABEE, IS IT
ANTI-HUCKABEE SANDERS?
BUT WHAT IS UNCLE TOM BUT FOR
WHITE WOMEN WHO DISAPPOINT OTHER
WHITE WOMEN?
>> Sean: BY THE WAY, SARAH,
KELLY AND, THEY TOOK IT WITH
INCREDIBLE GRACE, ESPECIALLY SAR
INCREDIBLE GRACE, ESPECIALLY SAH
INCREDIBLE GRACE, ESPECIALLY SAS
INCREDIBLE GRACE, ESPECIALLY SAN
INCREDIBLE GRACE, ESPECIALLY SAE
INCREDIBLE GRACE, ESPECIALLY SAS
INCREDIBLE GRACE, ESPECIALLY SAR
INCREDIBLE GRACE, ESPECIALLY SAG
INCREDIBLE GRACE, ESPECIALLY SAT
INCREDIBLE GRACE, ESPECIALLY SAE
INCREDIBLE GRACE, ESPECIALLY SA.
A SO-CALLED PERFORMANCE WAS SO
ASSOCIATION'S PRESIDENT REGRETS
OVER WOLF'S REMARK AND SOME OF
THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA EVEN THEY
CALLED OUT THIS SO-CALLED
COMEDIAN.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> I THINK THE COMEDIAN CROSSED
A LINE.
THIS ONE FROM POKING FUN TO
BEING MEAN-SPIRITED.
IT WAS VERY UNCOMFORTABLE.
I THINK THAT SARAH SANDERS
HANDLED HERSELF VERY WELL.
>> THE DINNER IS SUPPOSED TO BE
A JOURNALISM AND NOT THE
RED CARPET, NOT THE
MEAN-SPIRITED JOKE THAT WE SAW
LAST NIGHT, SOME OF THOSE I
REALLY THOUGHT WERE
INAPPROPRIATE.
>> THIS DINNER HAS HAD A LOT OF
BAD MOMENTS.
THINKING BACK, AS I WAS WATCHING
THIS CRINGEWORTHY PERFORMANCE IN
SOME RESPECTS GOING AFTER THE
APPEARANCE OF SARAH SANDERS,
WHICH I THOUGHT WAS
INAPPROPRIATE.
>> I REALLY THOUGHT THE PAIN OF
THE PEOPLE ON STAGE, WHEN SARAH
HUCKABEE SANDERS WAS BEING MADE
FUN OF, EVERYBODY FELT PAIN FOR
HER.
SHE FELT PAIN.
IT REALLY BOTHERED ME.
I KNOW THERE'S A BIG CONTROVERSY
ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT HER
APPEARANCE WAS BEING MADE FUN OF
OR NOT, COME ON.
>> Sean: FOX NEWS ALERT,
HANNITY AGREES WITH MIKA.
JUST AS THE PRESIDENT TWEETED,
THIS EVENT IS NOW DEAD.
THE PRESIDENT IS INCREDIBLY
SMART, NOT TO DIDN'T BUY THIS
DINNER WITH HIS PRESENT TO
PRESENCE.
THEY WERE PROMPTLY MOCKED
INTEGRATED, THE PRESS DESERVES
NO SUCH CONSIDERATION GOING
FORWARD.
I'VE SAID IT BEFORE, I'LL SAY IT
AGAIN COME AT JOURNALISM IN THIS
COUNTRY IS ABSOLUTELY DEAD.
THEY ARE NOT JOURNALISTS.
THEY ARE OPINION ADVOCACY HOSTS.
THEY DON'T ADMIT IT.
THE LAST STORY TONIGHT COMES
FROM A SOUTHERN BORDER.
FOR WEEKS, WE'VE BEEN TRACKING
THIS LARGE CARAVAN OF MIGRANTS
FROM SOUTH AMERICA AS THEY
MARCHED THROUGH MEXICO HEADED TO
THE U.S. BORDER.
MEXICO DOES NOTHING AND KNOW
DOZENS OF MIGRANTS HAVE ARRIVED
AT THE BORDER AND THEY ARE
DEMANDING ENTRY INTO THE U.S.
WITH SOME ATTEMPTING TO SCALE A
BORDER FENCE IN CALIFORNIA.
PRESIDENT TRUMP WADE AND ALSO
EARLIER TODAY.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> WE ARE A NATION OF LAWS.
WE HAVE TO HAVE BORDERS.
WE DON'T HAVE BORDERS, WE DON'T
HAVE A COUNTRY.
AND I'VE BEEN WATCHING FOR WEEKS
AS THE CARAVAN CAME UP.
AND YOU KNOW, THE MEXICAN MILES
ARE VERY TOUGH ON IMMIGRATION,
EXTREMELY TOUGH.
AND IT STARTED OUT WITH WEIGH
OVER 1,000 PEOPLE.
I GUESS NOW IT'S DOWN TO A
HUNDRED.
YOU GOT TO HAVE A WALL.